[Music]
hey sean yes sir howard doss ah
how you doing i'm doing good man busy
busy busy but just like yourself but i'm
doing well why are you so busy man
what's going on ah back to work oh yeah
how do you feel how's that going are you
getting used to it i mean it's really
cutting into your golf time it
definitely is i actually played today
before i came out here i did um where'd
you see
86 today dude that's almost your pr
right actually out of that particular
golf course i shot in 86 this past
sunday and that was also the best pr
i've had out there so it's a golf club
of oklahoma is where i'm at it's it's a
tough uh golf course not like that
nice little kitty one jason sales plays
that i think he left a word out there
it's uh golf mini golf club of yeah i
don't know it's all putting right it's
big boys that's actually heck if i could
learn how to put better that 86 could be
down about 81 or so well i know you're
busy with the new job and we're going to
talk about the new job and we're going
to talk about all of uh we're going to
talk about some pretty interesting
things that happened this week on the
episode yep
um but first we're going to have a drink
we are so this week and i know it feels
like we're always constantly like
plugging nashville barrel company on
here well we should because it's stuff's
delicious what does that say we say all
the time we're not like sponsored with
the guys there's nothing like that they
don't reach out to us but
uh
speaking of that we've got our good
buddy dirk in studio with us today who
owns mary's liquor store and we'll talk
about some of him as well but um yeah
mike hines and james davenport out there
at national barrel company in nashville
tennessee we love their products
i have recently signed up for their
monthly
um membership deal and basically just
once a month i think it's like 200 bucks
a month they send you a couple bottles
in the mail and you don't know what
you're getting and
uh my first shipment came in so this was
one of the ones we got and i'm excited
to try this so we have got a
straight bourbon that's finished in a
honey cask and you know the story about
them doing this in the honey's cask it
comes in a nice little 119 proof yeah so
what they did was they took a barrel
that they had and they filled it with
honey to the top like winnie the pooh
style right yeah
and they let that season and let that
honey soak up all that goodness from
inside of the
barrel
for about six months and then they
poured that honey out and sold that
honey
which
is fantastic
and then they went ahead and put some
bourbon back in that barrel and let it
sit for i think it was about a year
and then pulled that out and that's what
we're having today so here you go winnie
the pooh dirk's got a plastic cup
yeah there was one over here but man it
looked like
insects had died in itself
you taste a little you could taste the
honey in there yeah it gets it's it's
sweet in the beginning
it's kind of like me um this is the
second honey
product i've had you've got a couple of
those were they good times
yeah we don't talk about good times
that's yeah you know people frown down
on those well let's call them the other
company we have a couple of honey and
that one's pretty good but yeah this is
a this is top notch you can tell that
that's
that is flavored correctly
nice little seven year okay well anyway
so uh
jump back into
what everybody else wants to talk okay
so here's what i want to talk about so
on patrol live by the way
ratings came out we are three weeks in
and
we are absolutely killing it yet again
number one in the demo again both friday
and saturday night hey like i said uh
dirk and i both subscribed to philo
which we didn't even know fallow existed
so you've got to follow got a couple of
new people just because of you guys we
actually paid the three dollars extra
that you have to see yeah i think the
movies and more package i know that's
and again we have no affiliation with
them if you want to watch the show and
you don't have
i don't know dish direct tv or spectrum
or something anything does have those
anymore that's a good question who has
somebody was talking about cox cable and
i was like
hopefully somebody someday like youtube
tv picks up uh reels or something like
that then we go worldwide i know there's
a lot of people
in canada and central america and stuff
like that that love these shows so
hopefully well here's the one i want to
talk about i guess in south carolina um
you guys give me a bunch of shit because
i have a moped and it's it's a nice
little moped it's cute it's a vespa it's
cute and uh
we live downtown so it's kind of hard to
find a parking spot so you can whip in
do you what do you drive dirt well you
don't have a microphone so dirk drives a
large suv and dirk doesn't have a hard
time finding a parking spot because
every time i go down there his is parked
right so this moped excuse of no let's
say that i want to go down what kind of
shoes are you wearing right now i'm
wearing flip-flops you're wearing
fucking flip-flops that's why you drive
them open go ahead well i've got some
they're chaco flip-flops
yeah i mean the jesus angels but i was
like all right so uh the cop in south
carolina what's that big guy's name
gerald brown dude he is a mountain he is
a monster legit the guy is like almost
300 pounds and he's of muscle he is
massive and he's the highest peak in
south carolina right he is the peak in
south carolina biceps alone are like
hikers are walking around there did he
have to get a body armor custom made for
him uh i i think there's body armor
named after him what did they do to this
start with a barn and start puddling the
siding off of it pretty much they just
take tanks and mold it to fit his body
yeah that's what i was thinking but he
pulled over a moped what do you pull the
moped over for man i don't remember the
reason for the actual uh the traffic
stop so he's trying he sees a a man and
woman on a
right on a moped coincidentally both of
them are wearing gang cock south
carolina gamecocks which is
chad ayers uh alma mater where he was a
cheerleader but it was a whole different
story
um and then so
they're riding the moped they basically
try to avoid him you know we call it
ducking any time you know you see
people's behavior when they're trying to
avoid being around the police there's a
reason why they're trying to do it so
there was some sort of a traffic
violation and they try to duck him and
he pulls him behind him and right away
uh you're kind of watching the guy
that's riding the moped is trying to
separate himself and he's almost even
using the moped as a divider between
himself and garo so each way that garo
moves he kind of keeps trying to move
the opposite way and doesn't want any
conversation while the woman that's
there keeps trying to distract and talk
to guerrero as well well if a mountain
was walking towards you you'd try to
avoid it as well huh yes i'm i'm kind of
nimble um so i'd hope i could that i
could but that guy was pretty i mean the
guy on the moped he wasn't tiny he was
probably 5 10 or so but he decides
whatever's going on he's going to flee
he is going to try to make a run for it
so he takes off running and listen he
actually did a few little uh jukes some
some little tyreek hill uh you know try
to do a little juke left and right
didn't work very well um
but
gyro ends up tackling the guy and the
way i describe it look like a bear just
playing with a puppy
so do me a favor because you you
you're moving around and you make me
nervous and all that
huh
that's not true i'm getting like that
okay i'm saying
sir
do me a favor
and come here
[Music]
relax
[Music]
i'm trying to do this the easy way
are you listening
listen
i'm trying not to tase you i'm trying
not to spray you
relax
relax
relax
[Music]
yeah it looked like he was going to go
ahead and put him in a little baby born
and carry carrying back to the car i
mean it it was lopsided it was hilarious
so gary gets on top of the guy and he's
literally kind of got just one arm
wrapped around him and he's holding him
and he just keeps saying what are you
doing man you know he's like what are
you doing what are you doing the guy the
guy
listen people run from the police all
the time we call them you know kind of
passive resisting they want to get away
they're not there to really scuffle with
you they just want to get away
you know once you catch them they they
give up they you know put their hands
behind the back and they cooperate
despite being down on the ground and
right there in front of the camera this
guy did not do that so gyro has
basically just got him wrapped up
you know telling him hey man i'm gonna i
don't know if he says i'ma tase you or
spray you i don't want to do it i don't
want to do it and
gero never lost control of the guy he's
a big dude and just held on to this guy
and
he gets on the radio get some more help
there and the whole time all you hear in
the background is this dude's woman
screaming about get off my baby get off
of him get off him and it's just
what i love about this is for the public
that gets to watch the show
and you know because just somebody
driving by or somebody that just gets
their cell phone out and they only see
this large police officer down on top of
somebody and a woman screaming you're
hurting him get off get off of him they
have no idea what's happened and so
people watching the show obviously get
to see how this whole thing plays out
why it got to the point that it did and
of course with the woman still standing
there screaming in the background like
this guy has done nothing wrong and
gary's just picking on him yeah that's
ridiculous but guess what this might
come as a shocker power dirk i've got
some breaking news
the guy was doing something wrong what
are you doing he actually tried to kick
down this little um
i don't know look like a small little
pill container that had crack cocaine in
it so that's why he did not want to stay
around and deal with the police well i
mean a shocker that somebody i mean
what's the offense for that that's a
misdemeanor right no well no they're in
the state of south carolina possession
of uh it's a controlled substance is a
felony there
they don't have legalized marijuana
either they do not they do not have it
there nope so they they've got that well
uh i'm really a little upset that you're
harassing the moped society well
so like as we mentioned howard has a
moped uh i'm biased towards moped
drivers we did have a little click
called scooter gang but those applied to
like lime scooters
you basically had to have a credit card
to be in our crew
and a few few beers on a friday or
saturday night and you pretty much could
be a member strong sense of balance
that's it um
but the other day i was riding down yale
and there was a woman on a little moped
and
i mean she was i don't know 45 or 50
years old like a pair of yoga pants and
a t-shirt
and i was right behind her and every
time the light turned green i mean she
literally gassed it and put her head
down like she was just going mach one so
i recorded a video and said it was
pretty funny i was like yeah i said what
i say she could race you or you guys
need a race
that was like a little 50. that one no
that one big at all all right so uh we
you also had uh your crime of the week
which that's where they kind of focus on
you they they let you
talk about the crime of the week yeah
which was really interesting it was a
medical standpoint very well that very
much so first i actually want to go back
to the previous week's crime of the week
and it is it's a segment that um you
know that that basically that i do and
then curtis he does a couple sets he
does a segment for missing and they um
basically what i'm doing is a wanted
he's doing like a crime of the week type
of deal
and on the wanted deal we're just trying
to put information out to the public to
be like hey man this person is wanted
for a crime in this jurisdiction so
we're trying to help these law
enforcement agencies that are
some that are part of the show and and
others that are not just you know
somebody who is out in the community
we're hoping a viewer
sees this person recognizes a car or
something like that and gets these guys
in custody so the one we showed the week
before was an 80 year old widower guy
just finished playing golf had come home
in the las vegas area and this shit bad
guy was waiting outside of his house and
hit him over the head with a rock and
and you heard my age right 80 years old
forces the guy inside the house the old
man inside the house uh makes him open
up a safe he's holding an ice pick to
the the victim's throat at this point
opens up a safe the elderly guy the
victim has a gun in his safe a handgun
our shit bag takes the gun out of the
safe
he's still looking for more belongings
the old guy says hey i've got another
safe out in the garage so they go out in
the garage
the old guy smart he says man i need
some more light he asked the suspect to
open the garage door so the suspect does
and the old guy runs out of the garage
and this isn't broad daylight
well when he runs out of the garage
basically
everything we're able to witness is
picked up on the ring camera from the
neighbor across the street right the old
guy's running over to the house and the
suspect is chasing him
pointing the gun and trying to shoot it
and they get up close to the ring camera
you can see the guy
he keeps racking the side and trying to
shoot so he is literally trying to kill
this man
and the only thing that kept this guy
alive
was the old guy kept his gun unloaded
and no ammo in the magazine
so the suspect had stolen the gun just
didn't know it was empty yeah was
unloaded so he literally you see him try
at least three times try to shoot you
know rack the gun it just doesn't go off
so that guy ends up fleeing um he ends
up getting picked up down in mesa
arizona and this
maggot's name is armando dangerfield
and in november of 2020 he was arrested
for four of the basically same crimes he
is out on bond right now including one
of them was a 75 year old woman uh that
they had he had beaten and terrorized
inside the house so
you know people talk about these cash
bills and you know again we try to sell
the politics but there's fucking bad
guys that need to stay locked up man
they don't need to be out and this guy's
one of them so kudos we aired that on
the show and i think within 24 or 48
hours a tip came in that this guy was
down there in mesa arizona and he got
picked up so damn good for you yeah
which which brings us to this week's uh
deal this was something that happened a
couple months ago up in chester
pennsylvania a uh
basically a guy is out there supporting
his family i think he's got three or
four children
and he tows vehicles he works at a tow
yard and he does repossessions hey
that's rough work it is rough work man
it's uh you know
i mean it is i mean we've had to deal
with them a lot you know that stuff
typically happens overnight hours a lot
of times out of people's driveways and
you know
oftentimes people think they're still in
the car when they come outside there's
some truck hooking their car up and
driving it off
so it's a pretty dangerous deal but
this guy's first name is jamie and he
has just repossessed a car he's kind of
locking the gate up getting ready to
leave and he's sitting in his car and
another vehicle pulls up to him
and the guy tries to make a small
conversation he jamie just says he
realizes something's not right so he
tries to hit the gas and drive off and
the guy starts shooting and him hits him
i think once through the lungs and once
right through the left side of his head
he shoots through the vehicle shoots
right through the vehicle on may 3rd
2022 38 year old jamie king was ambushed
while inside his tow truck shortly after
repossessing a car
this security footage from the tow yard
shows the driver of the repossessed car
as he approaches king
and then shoots him in the head of point
blank range
chester police later found large amounts
of cocaine heroin and fentanyl inside
the repossessed car very disturbing
video to watch you see jamie get hit in
the side of the head and as you can
imagine your body just kind of goes into
a full lockdown mode shock
and his body just stiffens and when he
does basically he hits the gas
goes through and
hits a transformer at a building which
makes a big you know explosion type deal
and i think that happening
is what they think prevented the suspect
from
coming after him to try to you know
finish the job i think it made such a
big commotion
so this guy jumps in his car and takes
off
and uh the police end up looking inside
this car that was repossessed trying to
figure out why this guy was out there
and hidden inside of it there was
fentanyl cocaine and heroin damn pretty
significant amount so they've identified
together for a while yes well now this
dude you know it's for attempted murder
um his name is i think gabriel ali if i
remember correctly and they think he's
hiding out like in the north carolina
area so again you know the show is doing
quite well it's got a lot of viewers
we know there in the carolinas there's a
lot of people that are watching it
because we've got a couple different
agencies in that area
and so we're happy to show
you know a segment like this to be like
hey this dude is out there he could be
in the north carolina area even though
it happened in pennsylvania
keep an eye out for this guy you know
you might recognize him it's one of
those deals where a neighbor's like man
this dude he's staying with this girl
down the street right now or you know
i've seen him at the store absolutely
um so
watching the video of jamie and his wife
being interviewed man your heart just
breaks because you know who's pissing
happens part of his head is missing is
you know definitely deformed
life-changing uh incident for them but
it's in my opinion an absolute miracle
this guy's still alive based on what
happened yeah from a nursing perspective
it's pretty impressive what the human
body can
recover from you know i mean
you would think anybody shot in the
head's immediately going to die but it
looked like the way it went it kind of
grazed his head and they had to remove
part of his skull but i'm sure that
their skull fragments still inside of
his brain
sure can you imagine the headache oh man
i can't even imagine i mean that they
were you know we got to see when we did
this uh interview with him and his wife
we got access to some of the pictures
you know of him in the hospital
completely you know under right after um
you know him having to wear the helmet
the family first coming out there to see
him he talks about his teenage daughter
that was there every single day
um and i said this is four or five
months now that this has gone on he had
to learn how to talk again um learn how
to you know his whole left side was
paralyzed he's gotten that back again so
he's he's he's gone through a lot and i
imagine there's still you know much to
be done but man one of the best things
about it because we are doing twitter
live during the show and you know we
call them the op nation
the group of people that are following
us i mean every single week so far we
are trending in the top 3 4 of of
everything on twitter which is huge and
you watch the interaction it goes on all
night long and they're talking about the
different things that are happening on
the show but when these type of segments
come on are missing when we're typically
looking for a child that's missing
somewhere which we do every every
weekend as well and then this right here
i wanted you to see everybody start
retweeting it which is great because
it's getting it out to more and more
people even the people that are watching
the show you know people that are
following one another on twitter they
get to see it and it's funny i mean you
read the comments they're like find this
piece of shit you know i mean literally
those are the words find this maggot
let's get this shit back off the street
you know stuff like that so it's nice to
see people so passionate and so involved
yeah i mean the internet always wins
don't fuck with cats you know that's it
don't fuck with cats they'll figure you
out
well
this is good whiskey by the way it is
very good
james and mike did a fantastic job
kelly's working with him now too you
know
she's doing some stuff for him wonderful
yes okay so you um recently bought a
piece of property
yes that is true not too long ago and um
you had a shed on there we did
and uh
not any longer thanks to you and i but
go ahead so you had a chat on there and
i guess you were on this piece of
property and you went to get into this
shed and it was locked from the inside
that's correct yeah and so you um were
like hmm that's interesting i will force
my way into this
so you start pushing on the door and
shaking
my head started shaking you you ever
seen the movie old school yeah who has
it you know there's that part
yes or uh they have to do the debate you
know when they're they're battling and
will ferrell just you know who's like
the dumbest guy ever in the show was he
frank the tank i think and then he's
he's going up against the raisin cajun
you know i'm talking about you know that
the dimmer the democratic guy that's a
phenomenal debater and uh you know frank
the tank all sudden just starts spitting
off like crazy knowledge and at the end
he like just shakes and like breaks down
that was the moment that happened out
there like i just shook i went back into
like police mode like
what's happening here i've got to go
into them yeah i've got to go and get
this person out of my shed well i didn't
say there was a person but now yeah i
just gave it away so there was a person
living in the shit had no power no he
had power where'd he get power no it was
that so the property that that still had
so yes so this shed was a old
maintenance shed that was hidden in the
back part of the property behind trees
and bushes and it actually had power
there remember the guy had a fuck he had
a tv in there an air conditioner all
kinds
you know better than most people are but
so you called me because you know like
tearing up shit yeah yeah so i got the
guy out of there i want to say i didn't
have to call howard to get the guy out
of there i was pretty tough i got i got
him out of there so but yeah we wanted
to destroy the shed so that he could not
come back because
we're not living on this property it's
just it's a piece of property and we
didn't want him to come back and there's
some things that are happening out there
so we just thought we would expedite the
demolition process of the shed right and
you brought out like um like
sledgehammer and then we went and bought
a chainsaw we bought a chainsaw and that
was a it's all about the tools men men
and women so if it doesn't matter if
you're doing a project at your house or
trying to fix a car it is all about the
tools and i'm not i'm not gonna lie this
little maintenance shed was
they had added on they had built they'd
done it wasn't traditional building
styles they so whoever did it didn't
know what they were doing but over did
it very they fortified it right so it
was a little bit of a bunker so we were
in there and we were and this is i'm
getting to the reason i'm talking about
this so we were in there we were tearing
this thing down and it's dark and we
can't see in there we're not going to go
in there we're just going to tear it
down from the outside we start tearing
down this wall and i guess there is and
it was raining yeah it did rain on us
yeah there was a collection of bottles
kind of romantic and within these
bottles were urine and we could see
those yeah lots of them like 15 or 20
probably
it was not only you and i helping but
we had chase out there yeah and chase is
not very good at demolition chases chase
is good at a lot of things he's a he's a
young man that that works
um with us a little bit and um
phenomenal kid love it love him to death
absolutely
demolition he kind of pushed in a wall
and
busted open all this
fermented here so all this urine was
left
from the guy that was living there
because
he didn't have a restroom he did not
have a restroom and he tried to hide out
there during the daytime right because
of the neighborhood and so he would go
out at night so i guess during the
daytime while he was in there he painted
he peed in a bottle and he saved all
these bottles and they were on i don't i
guess i'd call it a shelf i mean it was
like a two by four that was part of the
frame of the shed and they were all
stacked up there and we knew what they
were
we knew not to touch him but he pushed a
wall down and knocked
several bucks several of them open and
i'm a nurse i'm used to bodily fluids
i've been around disgusting people
myself right and those smells but that
one was
quite powerful it was one legitimately
one of the worst things i've smelled
yeah we had to back up for a while we
walked away yeah it was that bad so
uh which brings me to what happened you
guys pulled over a car and in the back
guy had
some urine
pulling this car over he just almost
cause an accident
broad and long creek
what's up man
you got your license on you
appreciate it
he just pulled it right out in front of
that car back there that was my i didn't
even see him on the car that's why i
tried to speed up and get over i got you
i wouldn't um cause nothing got you
where are you headed to she's about to
go to my home bro there's a little bit
of weed smell coming from the car is
there a little bit in there yeah
how much is how much is in there nothing
like nothing no oh no
okay
[Music]
okay just a little bit
here just uh go ahead and step out for
me
anything on you oh no i just got off the
work okay just don't put your hands in
focus come back here come back here
all right how much is in the car that's
just the bag
anything else before i go oh no
no
just a little bit of smelly weed coming
from the car and he handed me some so
we're going to take a quick look
that protein shaker down there looks
like it's a better day
how long has it been in there oh no
i want to throw it away
you can't carry peace
i got a muffin
yeah
some people are dead
some people are in there
just
a small amount of uh weed and a little
yeah so man i can't remember what agency
it was uh it might have been like
berkeley county south carolina or
marion florida volusia florida one of
those i think felucia and
they had stopped a uh stop the gentleman
in his car and uh he was great i mean he
was very cooperative with the police the
whole time and
i don't remember the circumstances they
end up getting to a point where they
either i think they get consent to
search his car so they search his car
and they find uh bottles of urine and
this guy is just very matter-of-fact
about it yeah that's my piss
and he's keeping it because he's got to
do piss test at his work
and i i've learned this um
you know through the years that there
are places online there are stores and
towns where you could literally go in to
buy urine so if you are
a person who likes to consume illegal
narcotics and you have a job that
periodically test for drugs you can
actually purchase urine to go in there
or even fake urine uh to go into these
things you like wear it up against your
body it's supposed to get it to the
proper body temp that shit don't work no
i just said you'll know and i don't know
that that that doesn't work at all i
mean so uh i get tested quite a bit
because i'm always doing i'm a travel
nurse i'm taking contracts differently
and when i take a contract they have me
go through a background check and have
to pee again and i do all this let me
pause you real quick sure speaking of
traveling nurses uh did you follow this
nurse that
crashed out there in los angeles and
killed i think was like six people okay
so i'm not gonna get political bummer
get political on this she has like 10 or
12 accidents prior to this yeah she's
just it that's not indicative of all
nurses this is no you're doing the
police thing
she's just getting lumping you all
together yeah no i just i
just read that she was a traveling nurse
and uh she's being held without bond out
there but yeah she was also
well they've taken her i know they took
her blood so
um i don't you know i don't know how
long it takes for results to come back
on that so yeah she's not in the tribe
anymore we've kicked her out yeah that's
kind of that's kind of the way that that
works on that stuff but yeah um it was
interesting that they did flag her as a
nurse immediate chose to say oh she was
a nurse not just somebody
and she was an icu nurse so i mean she
should have a little sense and not be
doing that stuff but
we all make bad decisions some of them
were worse than others yup yep sorry go
back to a weird time about you being a
nurse and you have to take these tests
right so i mean i take tons of tests
like in the past three years i've
probably had like eight
drug tests so every time i go in there i
always ask so what's the weirdest thing
that you've seen
and when you go in there they give you a
cup and it's got a little thermometer on
it so it can tell you exactly what your
temperature of your pee is really and it
should be around 97 degrees right
because a good temperature is 98.6 last
time i was in there 98.6
it's great to have you back again i hear
that song no you don't know that song i
probably do if you play it but not you
singing it dirk you know that song no
derek don't know what it is that wasn't
fuck yeah it's like you have to play a
little bit later i'm gonna i'm going to
spotify i'm still listening
this is brought to you by spotify okay
so we have um this i asked her i said
what's some of the weirdest stuff you've
seen and she goes well i had a guy come
in and
his piss was 110 degrees
and he and he goes the jacked up thing
was is they had like a little subways
out there that had like a little
kitchenette microwave he had gone and
warmed up in the subway
and
we're we're playing a song for you sorry
i'm turning it down i'm listening i'm
trying to warmed it up in the microwave
and the lady from subways had called and
said hey i think you get one of your
your uh people for a direct test coming
in and she was like okay i'll look for
him and sure shit his best was that high
so yeah people do that kind of stuff
all right man well you're gonna play
this music for us i gotta i don't know
the name but it goes hey
98.6 it's good to have you back it's
like some songs like the 80s
not having any luck right now who sings
it i don't know i i typed it in on
spotify is this like on wkrp or
something that's a good show by the way
too dr johnny fever
here we are all right man
it's good to see you i'm glad you're
working again poor guy yeah that's tough
back to the back to the world of uh work
and
well we'll have some more updates on
ob live op live on patrol live you can
find it out there it's on twitter the
official op live instagram reels
reels channel do you ever have any op
shorts
i did ocean pacific shorts yeah yeah
that was a little bit shorter yeah back
in the hey they're back now you get that
four inch have you seen the dudes in the
booty shorts the booty shorts yeah the
guys with the thigh mates out
i have not seen this is this is a this
is a trend you should
tune in next week sean will have on some
booty shorts yes absolutely four inch
inseam you'll have the thigh me down
that's what my son went i mean dude all
he wears are little four and five inch
length shorts yeah you know it's 20
years old it's what you do i'm running
splits yeah all right well until next
week talk to you later
[Music]
you